I hope you brought your appetite for a
little competition because we're going
to play this Jenga that we've never
played before and I say you go first
ladies first please oh oh please oh God
darn it um all right okay for the rest
of the game you have to say hiya after
everything cuz you're into martial arts
right
sure all right
hiya these are really oh this going down
it's going down what's the most
embarrassing thing that's ever happened
to you
H what's the most
embarrassing I would say just every day
of my
life um I like I am the type of person
that if I'm trying to be really cute and
like cool and I'm like oh my God totally
I will eat it right afterwards right in
front of that person so uh all the time
okay um okay is it my turn it's your
turn oh God I know
I'm okay oh W tell us a behindth scenes
secret about Game of
Thrones well I was surrounded by English
people and um I'm not a formally trained
actor and everyone there is like very
you know Shakespearean thespians I am a
total not thespian I don't even know
what that means and so
um so they were all preparing I was like
just having fun talking to people and
they're like they need a second and so
they would go over and they would do
their they would do these breathing
exercises and these and and and do all
these things I was just like I was
totally blown away and I'm Drogo I just
have to Grunt and just like be menacing
and I watch Glenn uh he's
like and he knows I'm watching them I'm
just kind of like and he goes like this
wank I'm ready thank you for that behind
the scenes
ha all right your turn good one like
what's something you're afraid of
[Music]
hi well I'm afraid of death um I'm
really afraid of death I think about it
like far too often cuz I don't want to
leave and I don't want to be that not
there for my kids yeah that's yeah
that's that's and uh goats cheese you're
afraid of goats cheese it's disgusting
really if you want to lick a dirty foot
eat some goat
cheese it's like Tow
Jam that's amazing all right all right
last
one it's tough It's A Hard
One
whoa if you were stuck on a desert
island what would you
bring monol
I
I I'd also bring I'd also bring some
melee too just to offset it what's that
W vodka so oh yes exactly you need a
boom and then wait hydrate and then
dehydrate and then hydrate and then
dehydrate we want water if I was on a
desert
island H all right this the last one
what would your last meal be h
pasta we're like twins
twinsy
also that is like classic payoff and
storytelling the thing we set up first
is the way we close the loop and you are
an amazing Storyteller and you have a
story by credit on Aquaman 2 this really
also came from your mind and heart we
you tell us that as we come to a
beautiful close of our hang um well I
think you know this when you're an actor
and you love your job and if there's a
character that you love playing and I've
played it for so many movies over so
many years and I when we finished the
first one I went in I wrote a 50-page
treatment with my writing
partner uh Thomas and we went in and uh
we pitched it and it's all the things I
would want to experience and what I
think that me as a personal fan of the
character to play it I want this is what
I would want to see so I basically just
wrote kind of my dream list of the
things I would want to do and then James
made it in a beautiful script make it
personal and I know we personally love
you so much you are our person hey you
know
[Applause]
what the kingdom is in and December
22nd
you